subscribe subscribe
This IBAN is animals, for example, these
animals escape from smoke What happens
or injured, locals are
wrong, etc. We take them
too, our hormones are on fire Of course, in
many parts of our country, the
first priority of governments is usually humans,
animals are left behind  Whether it is cattle or
small cattle, these wild animals
stay behind, unfortunately, sometimes we
go to the burning places and take them out, sometimes
we help animals to evacuate before the fire
subscribe,
then we are sure that there will be a safer fire,
maybe we will put them in
a flat, wetland for now We were
finding our own ways from there, look
subscribe